it's crazy because you've um obviously
you know we've kind of seen cookies girl
from like
you know I remember the first time I
smoked cookies was with two chains and
probably
2010. shout out to titties yeah that was
around the time the Yoko was getting
played on the radio out there when I was
on the right that was that was around
that time and I remember you'd be coming
out to Vegas kicking with Franny and
[__] and
um
I kind of had like really got hip to you
but it's just wild to see like
the like was there ever a point in time
let's say in 2010 11 where you ever
could imagine that you'd be turning down
some of the exits I'm sure you've
already been offered and and you'd be on
the cover of a publication like Forbes
did you ever see it nah but I always
knew too like at the end of the day it's
all about how much work you put into
your craft right like if you stay
dedicated to your craft if man like even
last night dude I got home last night
and I just passed the [__] out hard 9
p.m out like
dead body my girls you remember how you
fell asleep I'm like nah she's like man
you were [__] out and just because I
just work all day long
so
I never pictured me in this position
because I was always an underdog I felt
like I always had to prove myself to
somebody I always had to work harder
than others but I also knew that like
one of my first
True Believers in what I do like one of
my first actual like investors and
partners and
you know he told me he's like bro like I
don't really quite know where you're
trying to go with the rap but I do know
one thing he's like bro you don't stop
and people that don't stop in no clear
are the ones that hit so I'ma stick with
you you should just stick with the pack
you're good at selling pack I want bags
from you and I think that you'd be
better off just focus on selling bud but
like man you just won't stop with this
rap [__] and so I have to stay behind
you I'm gonna keep pushing you because
that that's what [__] like you
aren't gonna lose and that stuck with me
I'm like you're right even the current
state of cannabis right now like the Wii
game is [__] up
a lot of people falling out a lot of
people suing each other a lot of people
hating each other a lot of businesses
going under a lot of gross failing a lot
of stores failing
um you know but we're still relevant as
hell we're still going because we still
put that passion into it like we still
care about this [__] do you think it's
also because you guys have a dope
business model I think too which is not
necessarily dependent on any because I'm
sure if people don't understand like you
guys what part like you guys have
Partners all over the country right it's
not like if you see a cookie store in
Detroit it's the same as the cookie
store in Oklahoma well some and I'm sure
some places it is the same partnership
right but for you guys like you guys
have kind of like put put together such
an incredible business model on the
storefront side at least where you know
um it's a quality control situation
where you obviously have to vet whoever
you partner with but at the same time it
kind of puts you guys in a position
where you know people are buying into
the name and the brand because the brand
is so prestigious yeah it's like ass
it's an asset like business model we're
not raising hundreds of millions of
dollars which allows me to stay in
control a lot of other people that raise
hundreds and millions of dollars in the
skin yeah they lose all their Equity
I've maintaining a lot of Mac where you
grow a lot and but what it does is like
it does three things we're able to say
ass asset light we're able to expand
faster anyone else we're also able to
cherry pick the best operators in the in
each market as they open up so
you know Albuquerque New Mexico we
opened up 11-3 right November 3rd that's
probably one of our best menus in the
whole country the weed looks almost
better than some of the wheat in
California they may use extensive 30
genetics on the menu store fully built
out like we gotta cherry pick those
partners that would dedicated to us
Nirvana and Arizona I was gonna say it
took you a very long time to get to
Arizona and that was a passionate
you know we [__] up the first time we
did we did a deal with the only players
in the game and they pretty much [__]
the weed up right they [__] the weed
up but they also shelved our growth but
now we found some independent guys that
you know the team at Nirvana they
understand what this brand means they
put the quality and we turned down
enough badges until it was time to go
we're like bro it's not hitting it's
like boom you got it yeah and they
dialed it in and they doubted in even
more from the opening and so it allows
us to partner with the right people all
around the country
and a lot of people say it's like a
franchise it's not like a franchise
because anyone can open up McDonald's
yeah you guys are being selective on who
you're gonna let we're being selected by
who we're going to [__] with we're being
selective on which markets are mature
enough to open up and we're also just
really understanding that like there's
nothing easy about managing hundreds of
Partners right it'd be easier to raise
the money and to build out your [__]
yourself in theory because then you're
the one controlling all that there's a
lot of egos there's a lot of there's a
lot of politics there's a lot of
personal
um you know interaction you have to do
when you have that many partners but I
like that [__] yeah and it also kind of
removes the like bureaucracy that you
would have to deal with in each City and
Market because at the end of the day
like you said in the Wii game it's
unfortunately it's full of like a lot of
cool people but it's also full like on
the corporate side bro like it's trash
bro like I miss medical days so much
you know when it was medical it was a
big risk still and people were having to
put their neck on the line and it just
was a lot more pure as soon as it went
legal a bunch of people had no business
being in this business got in this
business and they started getting in you
know Partnerships with Legacy guys and
kind of changing the way that they think
and what's really the real goal I mean
if you look at the two things I'm truly
passionate about food and weed it's
two things that really bring people
together no matter where you're from no
matter where you're at in the world you
can connect over food or wheat right so
like I'm in it for a bigger purpose I
know the brand has value I know there's
going to be some money associated with
this with this position later on in life
but for right now it's a struggle to
maintain to stay relevant to deal with
all these different partners make sure
everyone's happy everyone feels like
they're getting the attention they need
but I wouldn't I wouldn't change our
business model or the situation we have
over anything it's cool to connect with
people all over the world and you said
it not just in the country but all over
the world
we're about to open up London uh you
know medical side of London
um we're in Spain we're in Amsterdam
we're in Israel we're selling wheat in
Germany right now like it's cool to
connect with people all over the world
over some of you created from you know
the ground up in your house it's cool as
well it's wild man yeah you obviously
went through like some public disputes
with some more partners that were coming
up trying to sue you
um did you end up getting any of that
resolve what's the latest with that no
those things take years and those things
are like mentally training and
financially draining but like
you know I said it and I I can only talk
with very little on it but like I I know
100 that we're in the right and that
when everything comes alive people will
be like damn that boy went through all
that for what right and so I feel very
confident Where We Are No One's Gonna
Come Take cookies from me I am cookies
right no one's going to remove any of
the partners that helped me build this
along the way
and I think that's part of the
unfortunate thing about building
something big is when you build
something big people will try to come
take that [__] but growing up I didn't
give up my lunch at school I'm not going
to start doing it now and I'm also not
going to jeopardize what we all built
together as as a community because
a lot of people feel attached to cookies
and I mean a lot of people got tattoos
there's a man in Tucson right now with
your portrait and the cookies logo on
his belly yeah no that's that's real
right that's a real human being I saw my
own eyes yeah and so the easy way I
would be just to bow down and take
something from them and just step but
like no dude people are fully invested
in this vision and this brand and what
we built together it's not just my [__]
it's our [__]
all these operators around the world
they believed in what we build together
right so I'm fighting for it bro and I
feel like we're going to win at the end
of the day I feel like we're going to
come out on top it's just going to take
a lot of mental strength it's going to
take a lot of capital right right that's
why you stay grinding and it's gonna
just take dedication and loyalty from me
and my partners that's it